reasoning itself has costs and the
benefit of choosing the optimal decision
always has to be traded off you can't
spend the rest of your life gathering
data because then you know your life is
gone you've got to at some point act on
the information you have knowing that
you're taking a risk but still weighing
in the cost of inaction
stephen pinkett welcome to the show
thank you nice to be here
there was a time not long ago when i
thought that reading another elliot
yukowski blog post
or another chain parish mental model
definition about some cognitive bias
that i didn't realize that i had there
was a period where i was adamant that
that that was going to be the solution
to all of my
problems in life and then
i found out that it wasn't
why is it that i need a
glossary
mental models tool kit in order to be
able to function has
making sense of the world always been
this difficult
it always has we're i think we are
equipped to
reason about cause and effect and about
logical implications and about
probability when they
the problems are ones that we have dealt
with all our lives when they're
involved subjects that we deeply care
about that impinge on us but when it
comes to
general purpose tools that we can apply
across the board including to novel
situations like oh it didn't occur to me
this is another example of the sunk cost
fallacy or of the availability bias
namely reasoning from anecdote
having those tools at your fingertips as
generic
all-purpose
cognitive
tricks that you really do need to be
reminded of you need to know the names
of the fallacies and how to avoid them
the names of the normative models that
is
rules and systems of how you ought to
reason uh to
uh
to deal with novel situations ones that
aren't and abstract situations
daniel kahneman got asked i think by sam
harris when they did a live event about
after all of this time daniel learning
about the human brain and biases has it
made you any more rational and his
response was basically no what's your
thoughts on that have you managed to
make yourself any more rational
um somewhat i mean i'm uh we know from
the literature on biases that i'm
probably not the person to ask because
all of us are subject to a bias bias
namely
all of us think that everyone else is
biased but not us
uh so i might be the the person least
equipped to spot my own biases but i i
tend to think so and there there is
research that suggests that people who
are less susceptible to the classic
cognitive uh fallacies and biases have
better outcomes in life in general
they're less likely to get into
accidents to lose their jobs
to
break up their relationships
as always these pertain to averages
certainly less likely to be scammed by
psychic or
medical charlatans
so uh
so applying the average to myself
i would think so on average i would hope
so are smart people any more or less
likely to be rational
on average yes there is a correlation
between intelligence and rationality but
it's far from a perfect one so there are
plenty of smart people who are
vulnerable to cognitive biases uh who
are
fixed in their
beliefs and don't adjust them in
response to
changes in evidence particularly when it
comes to
beliefs that are sacred values of one's
own tribe one's own coalition one's own
political ideology the so-called my side
bias
that is you
steer your reasoning toward a conclusion
that makes your own uh tribe look good
where tribe can be your religion your
political party your uh
uh
your hobby group um then smart people
are uh just as vulnerable as less smart
people this is one of the conclusions
from keith stanovich in his book the
bias that divides us
uh stanovich has developed what he calls
uh somewhat cheekily a rationality
quotient as a
kind of complement or alternative to the
intelligence quotient and they are
correlated but far from perfectly is
there something that smart people should
look out for in particular with regards
to irrationality
certainly the my side bias namely are
you uh
are you really
committed uh to
some belief that is uh emblematic of
your politics
uh or your theory in some academic
dispute then it's uh you you're probably
susceptible to
various kinds of motivated reasoning
like
biased assimilation which is to say you
gobble up
information that seems to support your
view and you
stay away from or don't read or or or
nitpick to death uh evidence that goes
against your beliefs
are you trying to spin doctor everything
so that if there's evidence that would
seem to go against one of your beliefs
you try to find loopholes in ways that
you don't have to believe it and of
course we all do this
we're all
lawyers that that make the best
strongest possible case for our clients
but it it certainly is a way in which
each one of us can be
less than optimally irrational and but
of course it makes it all the harder to
spot those biases in yourself that's why
we belong to communities where it isn't
just up to you but you expose your ideas
to
criticism you allow them to be
challenged you have a community that
abides by
uh free speech so that any opinion can
be voiced and then evaluated the way we
undo our bias typically there there are
some
uh self-aware souls no doubt who can
step outside their own biases
more commonly other people do it for us
yeah it's interesting thinking about the
effect socially that we have i think a
lot of what we need in the modern world
is the ability to be rational while
there's social pressure around us it's
very difficult to exist in a vacuum now
because even if you are the most
excluded isolated person working in a
lighthouse in antarctica somewhere you
probably still have facebook and twitter
and an internet connection so are there
things that we need to look out for when
we're in a group particular biases or
ways that our rationality gets perturbed
and uh
perversed when we're in a group
yeah certainly to
be be open to
sources of information other than the
one that's going to ratify your your
side's beliefs so not just to read you
know the the guardian or the telegraph
but to dip into the source that you
don't habitually read
to um seek out sources that have
themselves cultivated a reputation for
objectivity and accuracy you mentioned
a prominent member of the irrationality
community eliezer yankowski although
also in that community is
scott alexander
writing under the uh in the blog uh
astral codex 10. and he does often will
do
literature reviews astonishingly
thorough and astonishingly quickly where
it's pretty clear at the outset that he
has not made up his mind
and he does his best to
say whether whether lockdown policies
are effective at
stemming the spread of covid a highly
politicized issue uh but when he did a
literature review he said
he concluded there's a number of months
ago that yes they are
somewhat effective better than not
having them uh but only after looking at
both sides of the issue and all of the
uh extant studies that he could find did
you see that he got married the other
week i died i i did see that yesterday i
just got the notice yesterday although i
knew that i am in the uh
the uh in the bay area this this year so
i had dinner with him a couple of months
ago and i met his fiancee oh amazing
yeah i saw the photo i'm on the mailing
list wrassle codex 10. it's like
it's so strange after years and years of
him writing under this anonymous
pseudonym and just being this person
well you have a relationship with their
words but not with them
yes and it's so bizarre to now see a
face to the words
it is indeed and uh and for for many
months until i met him i did wonder uh
who wha what was the actual physical
body behind this uh this brilliant
intellect
it's so strange how we we do attach that
sort of embodied sense to someone you
know the pseudonymity that the internet
affords and there's a lot of talk at the
moment as well about pseudonominous
pseudo whatever it is
pseudonymous thank you for walking me
through that word uh those sorts of
accounts increasingly zero hp lovecraft
is one of those i think it's like
orangetree is another one we have a
bunch of different people online that
are
uh deploying information but hiding
behind because they don't necessarily
want to put themselves out there and yes
it's interesting to think that scott you
know was doing that whatever 10 or 15
years ago
well indeed in his particular case he's
protective of his full name because he
is a practicing psychiatrist and he
wanted his patients not to um be aware
be affected
by his uh other identity as a blogger
and commentator
talk to me about basing bayesian
reasoning because it's a term that i've
come up against previously and yet i've
never really understood how to use the
principle of bayesian reasoning to apply
it to my own life on a day-to-day basis
yes so it's this is one of the uh kind
of signifiers or identifiers or identity
badges for being a member of the
so-called rationality community do you
think that that you know every person
should understand bay's rule uh and
that's that's almost an a a membership
requirement that you uh you you
understand it and endorse it it's uh the
the
eponymous rule of the reverend thomas
base from the 18th century and it's
actually
it's a it is an algebraic formula but
it's actually pretty simple and it's
already
spilled over into our everyday language
in the common term priors what are your
priors that is actually taken right out
of
bayes rule the rule is simply that the
purpose of the rule is how should i
calibrate my degree of credence in a
hypothesis depending on the strength of
the evidence so the idea is you don't
just believe it or disbelieve it you've
got a degree of belief from zero to one
and the key insight is as soon as you
take that conceptual leap then you can
apply the arithmetic of probability to
the problem of how to calibrate your
belief to the evidence
and so the uh
the the idea is simple the output the
deliverable the the point of bayes rule
is what's called a posterior probability
posterior just means after you've looked
at the evidence so when all is said and
done how much should i believe that
say
masks stop the spread of covid or
to what degree should i think that i
have
prostate cancer if i get a positive
prostate specific antibody test reading
um
now so
how do you figure that out well there's
just three numbers according to b's rule
first is the prior
that is before you even look at the
evidence the symptoms of the patient the
test result the the the data in the
literature how credible is it to begin
with
what is the sort of accumulated weight
of evidence and plausibility before you
before you look at a single data point
uh that's that's the prior now
admittedly there's some subjectivity
that goes into that
for a disease you usually take the base
rate of the population what percentage
of men have prostate cancer
uh it raises the question of you know
well
do you look at 65 year old men do you
care whether it's white men or black men
but let's just say that
you that uh
you start off with some kind of prior
then
you
multiply that by the likelihood and in
the
lingo of of a
bayes rule likelihood means if the
hypothesis is true
what are the chances that you would see
the data that you are now seeing so
let's say in the case of a medical test
of all the people say who do have
prostate cancer
what percentage of them does the test uh
correctly
pick that up it's the sensitivity of the
test in the kind of a lingo of testing
so that is technically probability of
the data given the hypothesis that is
you know we still don't know whether
it's true or not but if it was true
how likely is it that we would get those
those uh those results those symptoms
those test test data
you just divide that by how common the
evidence is across the board if uh if
the symptoms or the test results uh
occur a lot that is that there's a high
false positive rate together with a true
positive rate that goes into the
denominator and as we all know from
elementary school
if the denominator gets bigger the whole
fraction gets smaller
um and so it's just the prior times the
likelihood divided by the commonness uh
and it is kind of intuitive we all know
that if a symptom of a disease for
example occurs
for a lot of diseases you know fatigue
uh then just because i don't know rocky
mountain spotted fever has the symptom
of fatigue you don't conclude that you
have rocky mountain spotted fever
because fatigue can come from lots of
things that's the commonness the data in
the denominator likewise if something is
really going around a lot like omicron
then you have some of the symptoms that
that would be the prior you say well uh
you know i am feeling a bit uh achy
omicron doesn't seem like a uh
implausible um
uh
explanation uh and likelihood
uh two is kind of intuitive namely if
it were true
uh
if you
do have say omicron uh are you gonna
have a sore throat most people with
omicron do have a sore throat i have a
sore throat well that ups my
credence that i have uh omicron
anyway that's
bay's rule people are not very good at
kind of applying it
to novel situations
especially when the numbers are
presented
in a little bit the way that you and i
have in terms of numbers between zero
and one
if on the other hand you present it in
terms of frequencies that is
there are a thousand men in the
population uh 10 of them have
prostate cancer of the 990 who don't uh
10 of those will test positive of the
10 who do 9 will test positive you test
positive do you have prostate cancer
people are pretty good at saying well
based on what you said it's got a 50 50
isn't it if i give you the same numbers
the same information in terms of the
chance that you have prostate cancer is
0.01 then all that people
kind of blow off the base rate they just
think oh my god positive test i must
have the disease and then there
according to classic research by
kahneman and tversky people neglect the
base rates they reason kind of by
stereotype by anecdote and then they're
not so good so that's kind of the the
the base the base story and anyone who's
just heard it has all of a sudden become
much more rational
i'm not going to use scott alexander for
every example here but he does a thing
at the beginning of the year
where he makes predictions for the
forthcoming year by the end of it is
most of that do you think that that's an
attempt at
bayesian reasoning
yes so um forecasting rational
forecasting uh does use bayesian
reasoning as one of its essential
ingredients yes so for just to give you
a concrete example this is based on on
the work of
philip tetlock and barbara mellers uh
and
well who run forecasting tournaments
they have become more popular through
prediction markets where you can
actually
get skin in the game put money in the
line what is it what is the chance that
that russia will invade ukraine what is
the chance that uh inflation will exceed
ten percent this year and you yeah
you bet against other people but the way
that beijing reason comes in is a good
forecaster and good forecasters tend not
to be your name-brand pundits who tend
to have a pretty crummy track record
because they're always pushing their
political ideology and it blinds them to
the specifics of the situation but the
way bayesian reasoning enters into
accurate forecasting is the first thing
you start off with is the is the base
rate that with the prior so for example
will there be a terrorist attack this
year that will kill more than uh 10
people well the first thing that a
rational forecaster would do is go to
wikipedia look at the number of
terrorist attacks that have taken place
every year for the last 10 years in that
part of the world and say well
let me start with that as my
first guess and then i'll bump it up or
down depending on the specifics of
what's happening this year
uh likewise for for putin invading
ukraine they might start off with well
how many invasions have we of one
country by another have we seen
that's where that's my starting point
now let me increment or decrement it
and that's not typically the way people
do forecasting which is why they're not
particularly good at forecasting they're
not bayesian enough
isn't it that betting websites are
usually the most accurate ones when it
comes to upcoming elections i don't know
whether that's a myth that i've seen on
the internet or if that's actually
correct
so i think that
the so-called super forecasters in uh
tetlock and mellor's tournaments
outperform prediction markets but
prediction markets outperform just about
anything else yeah wow that's right
well because you've got a lot of people
with uh you know who are mo highly
motivated
to um
learn about the the situation it's not
just that they toss off some opinion
yeah it's unlimited skin in the game
that's right and uh the the what
ultimately counts is not reputation but
are you right or wrong uh and so it's
not like plugging the ideology making
your side look good the the proof of the
pudding is in the eating yeah what about
measuring risk and reward for people as
they go through their life
that's another chapter in my book
rationality
it pertains to what sometimes called
expected utility theory or rational
choice theory one of the uh less popular
theories people often blame it for uh
the whole homo economicus rational man
um it's basically the idea that you
should when you're faced with an option
under
a risky option
you should
multiply the probability of each outcome
by its cost or benefit it's its reward
or it's a penalty
um add them up and choose the option
with the highest um some the highest
expected utility that is probability
times payoff
um
now and there's a literature from
uh goes back 50 or 60 years several
nobel prizes have gone to
um economists and game theorists who've
shown cases where people don't seem to
uh abide by the uh
axioms of uh
uh expected utility theory but by and
large it isn't a bad guideline to start
with i mean obviously
we often live under not um
risk where we know the probabilities but
uncertainty where we don't even know the
probabilities as uh donald rumsfeld
famously put it unknown unknowns as
opposed to known unknowns
but still if you think through what is
the chance that something will happen
how good or bad will it be it it
probably would lead to some wisdom like
um
you know if i if i step on the on the uh
accelerator to get home faster because i
really don't want to be uh late for
dinner or miss the first uh you know
minute of a show
um and you know what's the benefit of
that now i am taking a slightly greater
chance of getting killed in a car
accident how much value do i place on my
life
if you started to think that way you
know or should i wear a bicycle helmet
should i fasten my my seat belts
you'd probably make a lot a bunch of
wiser decisions
or even more mundane ones like i just
bought an appliance should i also buy
the
additional extended warranty
now that costs typically about 25 of the
price of the product itself the the
sales people will push it aggressively
and the reason is the expected utility
calculation works out in favor of the uh
the store and not the customer namely
uh you you buy something
uh
unless it's one out of four of those
products is going to break
paying a quarter of the price for a
warranty does not make any sense you'd
be much better off just
occasionally
absorbing the price of the repair or
replacement and you're going to be ahead
i mean does it really does not make
sense to buy a life insurance policy for
your toaster but every i
every insurance company would be
bankrupt if that wasn't the case
well the thing is that for insurance
makes sense for catastrophic losses that
you can't uh recover from the place
you're you're you're in your house
uh for most people your car
um the livelihood of a breadwinner um
but for things where you really could
replace it even though you know it'd be
you'd be really annoyed if you had to
buy a new toaster the month after you
bought one
you you probably could afford it and it
doesn't make sense to keep forking over
money for every appliance that you buy
so
self-insurance makes a lot more sense
do you think about
balancing rationality with a more sort
of intuitive natural flow just generally
to life so rather than
a lot of the time when i find myself
thinking a lot about
the mental models and the biases that i
use as i move through my day i often
find myself getting in my own head and i
don't find as much ease or flow or
intuition with the way that i go about
do you think that there's a tension
there pulling between those two
there there is i mean there is a
phenomenon of as we call it overthinking
uh
but you know and they're
about 20 years ago as a result of a
bestseller by malcolm gladwell called
blink
there was the popular idea
people in in business love it that you
should go with your gut your first
intuition is uh going to be wiser than
overthinking that it's probably not true
in general that the uh
there are rare cases in which the gut
feeling is more accurate than reasoning
out but by and large you're probably
better
thinking twice
now granted a lot of times you just
don't have the information no one has
stated the probabilities it's not like
buying a lottery ticket where you can
look up the odds or a casino gambling
and so we have no choice but to make
intuitive
guesses
but you know in general not acting on
impulse is
is probably the why with the wise
philosophy of life the problem that we
have is that would
we're not privy to the codes behind
whatever the odds are of whatever it is
that we're considering right and we can
kid ourselves into believing you know
it's
for covid masking or for the prostate
cancer rate for men of your age in your
area of your particular genetic heritage
there are some things but most of the
decisions that we make on a daily basis
about whether to stay with a partner or
leave about whether to go to a new city
or not
where would you even begin to try and do
that i suppose that this is where
those more messy and emotional decisions
are where people are hoping that
rationality will give them a lifeline
out of it
and then ultimately a lot of the time
end up coming back to something that was
quite intuitive in the first place in
any case
sometimes yes and indeed it is true that
often that those critical probabilities
you know
no one knows and you can't find out uh
life life is uncertain
but here's there is a bit of advice that
i'm going to credit to my colleague
daniel gilbert and the psychology
department at harvard uh which is that
when people try to
uh imagine how they will feel in the
future
they're often not very good at it um
that we we probably give too much uh
credence to our own powers of
imagination
and that often you're better off looking
for someone at someone else who has
faced that decision and to look how how
it turned out for them
uh and uh
they've actually because then you're not
relying on imagination now granted no
two people are are interchangeable so
you know maybe their situations
different mirrors maybe the world has
changed you know that was then this is
now
still probably a lot of the time you're
better off at trying to as we you might
put a you know kind of gathered data
real world data for how it turned out
and it was it's particularly poignant
for me because
he
told me this many years ago when um
over dinner when i was at mit at the
time i had a job offer from harvard i
was agonizing over whether to take it or
not
uh we we had dinner and uh granted he
had an interest in the answer because he
was recruiting me to be his colleague at
harvard but he said he he said you know
most people when faced with an agonizing
decision rely too much on their own
power of imagination and you're you're
better off finding out how it really did
turn out for for someone who was faced
with that decision who went one way or
another and sure enough i asked two of
my i i was in the unusual position
perhaps that two of my colleagues from
mit had made the that exact jump they
had switched to harvard they had been
poached
and i
asked them are you do you regret your
decision or did it turn out well and
they both said it turned out well and
and um you know that that uh that
decided me so i decided to uh uh to
accept the offer and i have been happy
ever since i'm pretty sure that there's
some evidence that shows people who make
changes in their life on average
are happier that simply making a change
if you have a choice between staying
where you are and making uh or making an
alteration that on average people tend
to be more happy
i mean to the extent that that's true it
would say that i didn't necessarily
choose wisely other than uh deciding to
to make to make the move but i'm i'm
perfectly prepared to believe that not
least because uh once you have made the
choice you tend because of cognitive
dissonance that is uh cognition's
reduction rationalization
uh you know we we don't want to look
like idiots for having made the wrong
the wrong choice so we do tend to uh
find uh after the fact what made it the
best choice and and make the best of it
not everyone there are people who are
constantly you know blaming their
misfortune on uh on on some some regret
uh but that is interesting i was not
aware of that yeah i think a lot about
people that say uh it was meant to be
that they used that or um
yeah they go through perhaps some sort
of hardship and then come out the other
side and they saw it was meant to be
because look at the situation that i got
myself into and it always feels to me
like that person's completely destroyed
their own input into the good things
that they made out of a tough situation
let's say that you've got in some
accident or some sort of injury and then
you end up on the other side of that
finding a calling in life that really
speaks to you and i think well saying it
was meant to be takes away the agency
that you had from overcoming what was a
pretty shitty situation like you you did
this it wasn't meant to be you made the
best of a bad a bad environment
well and that's it's it's even more
pernicious when it's done uh in advance
and you and you say well yeah it's faded
uh uh uh you know either i'm going to
get covet or i'm not there's nothing i
can do about it either i'm going to get
lung cancer or not
uh and so that you
uh actually avoid making
reasoned decisions because you're
fatalistic and people with who believe
in fate tend to have uh certainly worse
predictors one of them
one of the uh ingredients of successful
prediction is believing in um
contingency that things could have
turned out different that the things are
not faded or in the stars
and i'm not sure if this has
specifically been looked at but i'd be
willing to bet that people who don't
believe in some sort of predestination
who who actually uh attribute some sort
of agency to themselves probably have
better outcomes in life and less likely
to get sick i think the goal is is to
have sufficient thinking that you can
make your decisions appropriately but
not so much that it slows you down
because i definitely have some friends
and i've worked with some people as well
who are
uh
overthinkers that make me look like i'm
the most rash like playboy in town
yes no and that is that is an important
point it's sometimes called in the
literature bounded rationality from
herbert simon the idea that reasoning
itself has costs namely time
information that you that you have to
gather
computational resources memory and data
and so on and the benefit of choosing
the optimal decision always has to be
uh traded off against the the costs of
the actual reasoning uh you don't you
can't spend the rest of your life
gathering data because then you know
your life is gone you've got to at some
point act on the information you have
knowing that you're taking a risk
but still um uh
weighing in the cost of inaction he
sometimes he who hesitates is lost
uh it doesn't mean it doesn't guarantee
you that the best outcome but uh it
sometimes means that uh that acting on
imperfect information is uh well always
essential
unavoidable i think it was is it seth
stevens davidowitz that wrote algorithms
to live by are you familiar with that
um i'm familiar with um
it's plausible i forget whether that was
his exact title he he did write a book
that for which i wrote a forward called
everybody lies oh no no no it wasn't
that one i think actually i think
algorithms to live by was um
actually uh a a guy brian christian
a christensen maybe or yeah uh anyway
yes i think yes algorithms to live by
algorithms
has a really funny uh way of how you
should pick your partner
so
it's averaged out that over 100
dates
um you should go for i think it's go to
30 or 33 dates go out on 33 dates and
then go out decide to pick the next
person that is the best out of the
people that you've seen and that on
average is going to be the best person
that you're going to find
well no and indeed that that speaks it's
an old finding it i think it was
i originally learned it in the context
of you're driving down the highway and
you want to know you want to figure out
where which restaurant to stop at and
you don't know whether it'll be a really
really good restaurant just around the
bend uh on the other hand you're getting
hungry and so it's the mathematics is
the same namely it is it is a theorem
i'm not sure why it comes out this way
but yeah sample about a uh a third of
the expected number and then choose the
first one that's above the average of
that the third that you've measured so
far uh so it applies in in that case as
well yeah again that's a really good
example because it's trading off the
costs of waiting indefinitely namely you
don't want to you know
marry your your perfect match at the age
of 80 because it's taken that long to
wait for them you know on the other hand
you don't want to uh propose marriage to
the the first good looking person you
meet either yeah uh what about
conspiracies they seem particularly good
at
subverting rationality
uh indeed and uh
for for a number of reasons one of them
is that it's they they fall into a
category of belief that is peculiarly
unfalsifiable
um they are memes in the original
richard dawkins sense of ideas that are
adapted to being spread by their by
their very nature
and the uh
the part of the conspiracy theory that
says that the
lack of evidence for the theory is proof
of what a diabolical and genius
conspiracy it is
that makes them uniquely uh
invulnerable to refutation kind of like
other beliefs like
god works in mysterious ways
or
if you
deny that you're uh
that this is racist that proves that
you're a racist
uh or
so there are
by their very nature some ideas are uh
contagious simply because they've kind
of
by their very
nature they are designed to evade our
cognitive immune system
also they conspiracy theories tend to be
moralistic they are
excellent
examples of a my side bias and there's
usually some villain and the villain is
often an identifiable
opponent such as the theory that hillary
clinton ran a child sex ring out of the
basement of a washington pizzeria now
needless to say it was not members of
the democratic party who believed that
conspiracy theory it was people who
hated hillary and indeed a belief like
that is kind of just another way of
saying boo hillary
uh the fact that it has
propositional content
it's kind of irrelevant to why people
believe it and and what that was one of
the major epiphanies that i had on on uh
in writing
rationality
and in dealing with these uh bizarre
beliefs such as that uh
jet contrails are mind-altering drugs
dispersed by a secret government program
uh or that coveted vaccines are actually
a subterfuge by bill gates to inject
microchips into our body to surveil us
and you ask
how can people believe these things and
part of the answer is it depends what
you mean by belief
that is for a lot of people
factual warrant empirical evidence
just that that's not why you believe
things when when it comes to things that
don't impinge on your day-to-day life if
it's going to affect whether your car is
going to run out of petrol or whether
there's going to be you know beer in the
fridge then people are very very attuned
to reality they kind of have to be but
when it comes to belief about um
things that you'll never encounter in
life like that pizzeria or hillary
clinton
people believe things because it
expresses the right values the right
moral it identifies
uh villains that you think are evil it
identifies uh heroes more often villains
in the case of conspiracy theories
sometimes it's an identifiable one like
hillary clinton sometimes it's just a
general
and a hatred of the establishment of
elites of institutions there's a fairly
uh
sizable
minority who just believes that the uh
has kind of a need need for chaos as
michael bang peterson put it that is
they just
think the whole system should should
burn it's so uh corrupt and evil and so
any
concentrated source of power governments
corporations
uh science
scientists the public health
establishment could often be figure into
these conspiracy theories the theory
portraying them as uniquely evil and
insidious that's fascinating that's such
an interesting way to look at it it's
kind of like mental laughing
in a way these people doing live-action
role-play but founded within their own
minds one of the things that i found
really fascinating about conspiratorial
thinking especially recently is that
over the last two years faith in
institutions has just gone through the
floor we've continued to see the people
that were supposed to know what they
were doing and be in charge just
put their foot in their mouth
on live camera daily sometimes
just over and over and over again we've
seen
whatever duplicitous purposeful neglect
just idiocy play out in front of us and
i think that that has enabled people to
have far more belief in
non-typical bureaucratic
um what do you say
positions of power speaking truth we
just have no we have no time for it
therefore we're going to make our own
truth here but increasingly now people's
i see a lot on the internet that people
say look when you're saying conspiracy
why shouldn't i believe in conspiracies
this was a conspiracy and that was a
conspiracy and the definition of what a
conspiracy consists of now has started
to be expanded to include a lot of
different things conspiracy used to mean
something that was basically totally
unbelievable but now because the
boundary of what is true and what isn't
and our faith in institutions has been
eroded that really anything
is permitted to be a part of a
conspiracy it's no longer
flat earth
and and and beyond it's a whole host of
things that come back from that towards
stuff that me and you probably might
even have believed
yeah so a couple of things one is that
that uh yeah some many conspiracy
theorists say well well look there you
know the cia really did uh mount an
invasion in the bay of pigs in cuba in
1961
they the cia really did overthrow help
overthrow uh our bands in guatemala and
moscow deck in iran but still there
that is a uh
you know unwillingness to consider just
how many probabilities would have to be
multiplied for something as
uh outlandish as that the moon landings
were faked or that
uh jet contrails are
uh
tranquilizing drugs how many people
would have to be silent how many people
would have to not screw up
uh just how many pieces would have to
fall into place so that quantitative
thinking of um you know a conspiracy one
kind of conspiracy is can be very
different from from another and in fact
it's vaguely
it's even stretching it to call say the
bay of pigs a conspiracy there was
government secrecy as there always is
but it doesn't mean that you know
anything can happen
and it's true that trusted institutions
have gone down since they're
uh although it's
important to keep in mind that probably
the default is that people
don't trust institutions there was kind
of a peak in the 60s
where trusted institutions reached their
high water mark and they've been sinking
ever since
but
and uh it isn't helped when the
institutions themselves don't take steps
to safeguard their integrity and
objectivity and either when you have
experts that either make pronouncements
as if they were oracles they don't kind
of show their work that is explain how
they arrived at their recommendations
but just you know trust us we're
scientists
that just as as you say that just sets
them up for failure because no one is
infallible
even our best experts are going to make
mistakes that doesn't discredit them
that's just a reflection of the fact
that humans are not you know oracles
with a pipeline to the truth
um that should be made clearer that our
starting position in any new phenomenon
is ignorance you know sars cove two uh
popped up and you know no one knew
anything and that should have been clear
and and should always have been that the
public health instructions should be
based on the following evidence that we
have so far
this is what we recommend for the time
being that at least would have helped
the other is uh
many of our institutions are
uh are are flagrantly politicizing
themselves they're just advertising we
are a branch of the political left uh
they use the vocabulary the can't words
the cliches and people who
aren't
um
haven't identified themselves as part of
that
branding that political coalition are
just going to say well this is just
another uh another bunch of you know
woke academics or or or journalists and
they've kind of set themselves up to be
rejected uh under the
principle that applies to all of us that
we tend to be more receptive to people
from our own uh coalition
we made it stephen pinker ladies and
gentlemen stephen what are you working
on next what can people expect whatever
this year or next year
well i have for a number of years been
um working on the psychology of of
common knowledge in the technical sense
of i know something you know it i know
that you know it you know that i know it
i know that you know that you know that
i know that you know that i know it ad
infinitum and i think we're even though
that sounds like it would just make
anyone dizzy to think through and it
does
we have an intuitive sense of common
knowledge in the sense that something is
kind of out there or public or you can't
take it back
and i've been exploring how that enters
into a range of
psychological and economic and political
uh phenomena and that would be the topic
of my my next book the psychology of
common knowledge pretty cool i like it
cheers steven thank you very much
thanks chris thanks for having me on
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace